えっはぁ
ドーム肇社長です世の中にはたくさんのかっけー男がいると思うんだけどもまぁ自分で
言うのもちょっと癪なんだけど俺もまあ比較的イケてるをとかだと思うんだけども
もっともっとイケてる男いるんです
数少ない俺もあ
こいつかっけーなーって思う男の中に gackt って男がいるんですよねー
作成ですよはい2もうマジでたっけーいまここ
gackt のスタジオに来てるんだけども表は gackt からなるべく
男としてカッコいいところ娘れ部分は全部娘抹茶ず gackt という男がどこまで
入れてる奴なのかしっかりと俺がこの目で見定める
まあまあった瞬間誰か
が知れる男だったらそこまでだと思うんだけども24時間しっかり密着してくるねこぜ
痛さあそこに座ってるのた文学とだか
好きしみ出してく
おっん
マックスレイしまーすそうします
よろしくお願います全部佐藤と申しますよろしくお願いします
ハーフお願いします忘れましてほっか寿命して外れますですねヌー中
いる混ざる本当に
何だろうあの今日はですね京都ダクトさんのお時間がいるー
されるのであれば gackt さんの的なところを吸収して帰りたいと思います備中
熊沢でしょうーの
んいやもうそんなね3書きたいんでしょうかトレーニングところ
趣味でありぜひ宜しくお願いします
よっしゃいます eh
あっはい中だけで先生とお呼びという実施したらた言うされ先生というソ冷静じゃない
ですあっ
始めます
これはいったい池ではおっちょっブーベロそう
先生僕ですね今年後半禁止してるんですよ
調べた先生もお米を食べていらっしゃらないというこの顔
今年22年22m て大ビジネ
食べたくならないですか i s ですよねー
どこでしょ自分が死んだと思ったら死ぬ前に米炊いて
きっちりすぎっ国から僕は米炊いてくれて言ったらも退きだ
西からナースコールが込めた久保田みたいなチャンスを決めたことで会う
たらそれがいいです
いただきました
すぎですぼく込めた売れないだけで1日2回
ラーメン食べたりするんでしょ
一律にか選べたらけど光麺食べないで次に変えラーメン食べたら神ズマジっすか
選手圧ラーメンは1年に1回裏かなぁ年日ラーメン
僕くらい48だけど見た目が実際に4周走る若く見えるのは
じゃあやっぱり食生活をたに節制できるくん
食生活が一番次に運動後はストレート6ないように好きなことするっていううーん
それぐらい
いやトレーニングポスターぜひ申し上げますはいます
連れはへ
何しまーす
[音楽]
うわぁ
広くないすか俺ん家にあるトレーニングるー
たよのに並ぶ
声ですね
こちらのダンサーとか全部からね
さってもらって直径はスコーンの風土がして
おおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおん
特定して足を上げて足を下ろすんだけども私は
事例一切使わない状態で
[音楽]
いやーと思う bg わー
まあ今の40杯に雪よ設定
幸せ依頼ください5号沿い
ウットはに占めるそうをを含んではい
で君を出ねぇ
そこいい脚通してそれでいい走りをしてはーい
芦田はさあて作ったキュッです
主成分
それに入って
指定
ただで外国産ちなみには程遠いかーこれ前に続く空高く飛んだよ魔実家
先生これは一体それぞれ動きせるボール型ケ丘
吸気を見てもらってほしいでマットの上の例にして
はい結構いいし体おりませそれは行って耳でおっぱい含みすぎると尿じゃないんだから
もうちょっとそれが得てください
ています
先生先生
上質な全部ね大丈夫ですよね
皆さんが全然
はいはい
えっはいはい
[音楽]
大丈夫202塾ええええ
today
それでいてしていいですこれも会等ございますね
スティングレーいいんですか
言語ここはい
恐王へこれから
どーん岩するぞ
しっかりスポーツ家ですけどなぜか
いきます
英語
対応
[音楽]
ています
スコッチいっぱいですよやれがを結構ですねそう分かるとミスト汗だくなんですよ僕の
ほうが
学校さんやばいマジで先制ありがとうございましたトレーニングです
レイヤー
いやすごいですよ本当に
ぶーぶーっ
準備できたら出発入られます
知ってればいい
あーねっ作田かっこいい先生
ろうそくが階段を押されすぎる
ないかって
海外おもしろみたりくっはくるですかも
パッひっ
[音楽]
紅葉
me
ここいい
これはファイルノート部品蔵書マットを持ってるお金ございます
中はクリア聡明トータルギアスクロックシャンプーとコンディショナーを使って上がっ
て行きたいと思います
もう着くをに学生
スイートははございません
ああ
me
[音楽]
ああああああ
あった
ね wh
[音楽]
me
これが楽さんのバーン
ええええええ
俺が学この気持ち母はれて来廊
次は gackt さんの撮影の現場に来ました
お客様もうすぐ到着するともんですけど
先生を待ちたいと思います
持ってません
めっちゃ崩してます恥ずかしいですよしておきになさらず
難しいって
鎧を始めました gackt さんの存在が合う
浮気がやりとしてますねー
bn
ni
ちょっとかっこいいすげーで思って近くで見てみますうーん
[音楽]
voodoo
ani came
ええええええ
はいえーい
me
ええええええ
ああああああ
をへ
地下次々ちゃっていいですか
うって言ってここからはダクトさんの方の撮影でございます
頑張ってきます
そうん
スタンバってすぐ感じ方が違うんだろ
はいいう形になりました最後は gackt さんの夜ご飯でございますディナーです
いきましょうします
佐束です作れそう夜ご飯でしょうねそう
陝西省は1日おつかれさまでしたございましたよろしけれ
ん
やつグァバのキャビアのせ
ben ん
[音楽]
がおいしいおいしいそれは
バクトさんはいつもなかったり福祉女島僕は自分の人生の中のプライオリティフェチ
使ってそのプライオリティは美味しい物好きな物を食べるではない
とがすごいです
凡人するプロルーティングはん
gackt やるためにも皆にブラックととして答えられる
コンディションでつなげなければならないん
早速が良いってその所しました
何年を組んでもダメダメ食べたくってやるとストレス溜めるから1週間なんだったら
こういうん
1か月が思ったらっていうのを決めとけばそこに向けて頑張りません
そういう風に見えでは続かなかった人たちも続けられるようなと言う
[音楽]
僕は今
1日1週間だったら何年いっぱい
ガキさんの寸盛クラン的に何歳まで生きる予定ですよね
うーんイキリ予定は正直決めてないけど
たり教
一生懸命いっ
朝起きたらいい
1問万が一だと思うけど
周布位はキーと撮った
なのです
生きてるんだけど
が聞いてもっ
[音楽]
あります升頂きます
あー腹気にずした
うん
だこれこれも2ですどれ嫌すぎるじゃなきゃですよね
版水化物での有名ごちそうさま
うんん
[音楽]
もういいんですか
すごいで像いうかごちそうさまでしたも叱って入っ
の前私とされそうなん
はいというわけで今日は1日100とさ先生にめっちゃさせていただいたんですけども
や本当に素敵ですありがとうございません
楽しかったよ思った以上に各フィクションでほっつだというでしょ先生
僕もあるだろするでマレーシア遊びに来ますいろいろ見せたよっ
本当ですか
おっとごと捨ててる人とスってすごい
素晴らしい方なって今日改めて思った今後ともよろしくね
であっ強い力ああ
普通にできましたよねあーやっぱいつかお会いしましょう
あれせましたといいですね
男に蛙
男にがいて帰ってきますプーチン数噛みまくっていう
だーってるんだよん
新たなんですか
[音楽]
昨日はかっこいい男性になるために
密着してきたわけですがまぁ自分磨きのケアって必要だなって改めて感じたねー
入って上で今回使用したこちらのクリアは毛髪で科学と皮膚科学の融合が叶えた
神道州から来てあ大人の男性用ヘアケアということで健やかな頭皮と強い髪へ導く
クールな大人の見出しないアイテムとなっています
クレイを使って自分のための塔否定をすることで見た目も境地も自分に自信が持てる気
がするので自分らしさを大事にして
一方としていいなと思いましたみんなにもそんな気分を味わってもらいたいので
はじめしゃちょー化計画に参加して自分らしさを磨いていきましょう
外れ者ちょっと計画キャンペーンは6月の1日から失楽の31日まで実施しています
なんと任天堂スイッチライトとスイッチのソフトが合計30030名様に当たります
以後印税
それ他詳細は概要欄をチェックしてください
俺も男を磨くぞ
うっしー
すぐ朝から腹筋豪快してくるから
う
[音楽]
うっうー do